hello and good morning it is 7 a.m this
is sky news breakfast our top stories
bracing for the cold weather one in four
say they won't turn their heating on
this winter because of rising energy
prices
the labour party says government-backed
home insulation served more than halved
this year resulting in people needing to
spend even more to keep their homes warm
and i'm at a car booth sale in bracknell
where people are trying to find new ways
to boost their income amid the cost of
living crisis
170 arrests in a major police operation
against organized crime in merseyside as
detectives make a fresh appeal for
information to find the killer of olivia
pratt corbell
ready for launch nasa says all systems
would go for its space launch system the
first stage to eventually sending humans
back to the moon
calls for more international aid for
pakistan as the death toll from flash
flooding passes 1000.
johnny depp drops in for a surprise
appearance at the mtv awards there are
big wins on the night four singers harry
styles and taylor swift
[Music]
and get your horns whistles and flags at
the ready it is day two of notting hill
carnival
[Music]
in the sport rory mcilroy becomes the
first player to win the fedex cup three
times after success at the pga tour
championship finale
and in the weather it's mostly fine and
dry it'll be quite cloudy but there will
be a few showers around too
and at a quarter to the out we'll take a
look at the papers with the uk editor of
the big issue paul mcnamee and the
author and broadcaster emma wolfe
[Music]
and thank you for being with us one in
four people say that they won't turn
their heating on this winter an
indication of the way that the cost of
living crisis is going to affect tens of
millions but despite the signs that many
are fearful there are still no firm
plans in place to help people through
the crisis we'll have to wait another
week until conservative party members
vote for a new leader and with it our
new prime minister now one way being
suggested to alleviate the coming crisis
is a freeze in energy prices being
proposed by both the labour party and
the liberal democrats now at this point
neither liz trust nor she sunic have
said that that's something they would do
now average household energy bills are
going to reach
3549 pounds a year from october and
there are warnings they're going to go
up again massively in 2023
polling commissioned by the lib dems
show that 23 percent of uk adults are
planning not to turn on their heating
this winter that rises to 27
for people with children under the age
of 18.
the research also says that nearly 7 in
10 adults will turn on their heating
less
this winter and 11 percent rising to 17
of people with children will take out a
loan to try and pay for their energy
bills
now the labour party said that the
number of homes being insulated have
more than halved in the first six months
of this year the party claims that had
ministers acted last year two million of
the coldest homes could have been
upgraded by this winter saving
households more than two billion pounds
on their energy bills this year alone
the department for energy business
industrial strategy acknowledged a sharp
fall in the second quarter of 2022
saying that it was due to a transition
between efficiency schemes
well of course in a week's time we're
going to know who the country's next
prime minister is and it's then that we
can expect to get some detail of how
they intend to deal with the cost of
living crisis now analysis by sky news
has suggested that people relying on the
state pension could be left living on
less than 11 pounds a day from next
april thomas more reports
inflation running at 10
money doesn't go anywhere near as far
now as it used to new research shows two
in every five people aged between 55 and
64 are struggling financially or up to
their neck in debt those slightly older
who are trying to live on the state
pension are also reeling jackie shops at
this oxford market to try to keep costs
down she has parkinson's disease and had
cancer not only does she need to eat
healthily but her treatment has left her
with dental problems and the bills are
mounting up
my teeth are falling apart
in fact
i can hardly talk because it's still
painful i won't tell you what it's
costing me but most of my money will be
going on dental treatment and i've got
to have it i want to eat
i don't want to be in a situation where
i can't
eat food
analysis by sky news shows the full
state pension is likely to rise to 10
600 pounds from april if inflation
remains at 10.1 percent next month when
rates are set
but at the same time analysts expect the
typical energy bill to soar to more than
6 600 pounds
that would mean gas and electricity
costs will account for 62 percent of the
pension leaving older people with less
than 11 pounds a day to live on
all those people that are calling our
helpline you know they know to the penny
how much money is coming in and how much
money is going out waking up sort of in
the early hours of the morning where
electricity is cheaper to boil the
kettle uh for the next day so they can
have a hot drink and talking about sort
of cutting back on
fresh fruit fresh vegetables
because they can't afford to waste any
of that food
tony worked in an office for 40 odd
years and managed to put away a little
in savings when times were good but even
that's not enough to give him the
retirement he was hoping for
i could get a second job but it might
well kill me i've
i've got helped certain health issues
you know diabetes and uh
various injuries from over the years
with the back and knee so
it wouldn't be easy for me to get
another job but it would be possible but
it would probably
shorten my existence liz truss is
reportedly considering a cut in vat of 5
and allowing people to earn more before
paying income tax
but neither she nor rishi sunak have
given any public details of how they'll
help in this spiraling crisis
thomas more sky news in oxford
a research by the pension provider aviva
has shown that 43 percent of people age
55 to 64 say they're struggling
financially almost a quarter say they'll
sell unwanted and unneeded items in car
boots or online in order to try and
improve their income well let's uh bring
in our correspondent elena veselninovic
who's had a car boot in bracknell malaya
good morning to you so i mean what kind
of things are people planning to sell
there
well traditionally this has been the
place to go if you want to bag yourself
for bargain but what we've been hearing
from people that increasingly here it's
become a lifeline for the local
community you can come here get what you
need from really a fraction of the
retail price now if you're a buyer or if
you're a seller you can pay a small fee
and then you get to
come here and sell your wares and i'm
joined by val blackham here who's been
doing these car boot sales since the
1980s
val what have you noticed recently with
the cost of living crisis spiraling
well recently people are looking for
more bargains than they've ever been
looking for before
and with the fuel increases and
everything like that people are looking
even more than they ever used to be
so it's a good way to come out and buy
really interesting things or things that
are really practical that you'd like to
buy for your home or for the garage or
for your car or anything like that
really and have you noticed any change
in your customers behavior and how
they're haggling famously this is a
place where you can haggle
that's right yes people want to haggle
even more than they have done i mean
back in the 80s they always wanted to
haggle but i think it's more like on the
continent now where people haggle and
that's what they're used to doing and
people haggle even more now because
they're really looking for that extra
pound or two off you know and what would
you say is the advantage just coming
somewhere like here to basically grab
what you need for your home it's a
really big car boot sale it's a good one
to come to you get lots of buyers that
come around and have a look and it's a
social thing as well you come out you
meet people you have a chat and i think
it's just a good place to come
thank you very much well there's
everything here from this lovely
crockery to fabrics uh so it's
increasingly a way to come and get what
you need and not pay too much for it
val thank you too
all right let's bring in now the
conservative party mp and supporter of
rishi soon at victoria apprentice good
morning to you victoria apprentice thank
you so much for being with us this
morning
now you will have seen the news of
course that uh it's reported that one in
four people aren't going to turn their
heating on this winter we're facing a
crisis aren't we why aren't we hearing
exactly what this conservative
government are going to do to try and
help people
well it's difficult at the moment as i
think everybody in the country knows we
are in the middle of a leadership
election and
neither candidate understandably wants
to set out in detail fiscal plans until
the leadership election concludes next
week but that's not to say that a great
deal of work isn't going on with
ministers
and with civil servants behind the
scenes to get ready to help people
through the cost of living crisis this
winter we completely understand as
government that last friday's
announcements from offgem were very
frightening
for most people in the country actually
who who are concerned about energy price
rises what i would say is that the
government is working up plans to help
people there is a great deal of support
already in place people shouldn't suffer
alone and worry alone
they should access for example if if
they're concerned there are things they
can do
there's a really good website cost of
living dot campaign dot gov dot uk
which sets some of that out and i know
that many broadcasters have been setting
out support as well
you need to contact your supplier if
you're worried you need to contact your
council because there's a great deal of
public money available for households
that are worried we've given money
directly to pensioner households because
we know that they're on a fixed income
and they worry very much
about putting the heating on
but please uh the message from
government is yes i know this has been
difficult we're in a leadership election
but there will be a plan to help people
through the heating problems that they
will be suffering this winter
i mean you'll appreciate victoria
apprentice that that message probably
isn't getting across you've seen some of
the figures about how concerned people
are i mean the labour party say that
it's a zombie government lord ricketts
said that the government has been adrift
i mean which one of those is it
i really don't think that's true i'm a
minister who's been working on food
farming and fisheries for the last few
years
i worked very hard throughout the
pandemic and was able to set up
cross-government groups to help people
in food poverty for example that work is
still continuing and i would like to
reassure
people who are concerned that we
continue to work as ministers and as
civil servants on on the issues that
really are concerning people that's one
of the reasons in fact that i am
supporting rishi for the leadership of
the party because i saw firsthand during
the pandemic how he was able and willing
to target support at households that
need it most he earlier in the year when
we were worried about the cost of living
he put in place a package of support
it's clear that more will be needed
because energy bills are going up even
faster than we
expected and much faster than any of us
would want
this is a direct consequence of the war
if it's nobody's fault but it is right
that government
works
with people in the country walks hand in
hand with those who are concerned to
make sure they have the support they
need i mean you as a supporter of rishi
sunak he was of course the one who
brought through the furlough scheme to
deal with us getting through the
pandemic would you like to see a similar
package of measures coming through to
deal with what's going to be the worst
uh energy crisis in a generation i do
think if rishi is elected he has shown
repeatedly during the course of the
pandemic that he can step up step up
these schemes none of us had heard of
furlough it was a scheme that he
invented it worked it meant we have very
very low unemployment at the moment
we were really worried about at the
beginning of the pandemic that lots of
businesses would go to the line that
people's jobs would be lost that hasn't
happened because of rishi's direct
intervention i am confident that he will
be able to step up
and help people through this new problem
largely caused by the war in ukraine
i mean do you think that this leadership
contest has just gone on too long
well it feels like a long time from my
perspective i must say but i must too
i'm sure i think it's right that the two
candidates have had the opportunity to
set up their stall to be tested
thoroughly to go up and down the country
meeting people not just conservative
members but to really engage with the
general public as well that's always a
good thing what i would like to reassure
though is that the business of
government has not stopped i've got
important farming announcements later
this week coming out the government's
continue to work my departments continue
to work and and that's obviously right
now as a minister in their department of
environment food and rural affairs um
you will have some responsibility for
the way that our waterways are treated i
mean what responsibility do you think
government has
in the fact that we're seeing our
waterways being polluted right now
sewage being dumped in rivers it's
really on the coast of waters we're
really concerned obviously about the
difficulties that have been going on
particularly with
sewage discharges into water that people
then understandably in the lovely summer
weather we've been having
want to swim in i'm a really keen
river and sea swimmer myself in the
summer and of course we need to make
sure that our water is clean
that's one of the areas of work on which
a great deal of effort has been put in
this summer
and
we've got a really comprehensive package
of measures to stop water companies over
using these sewage discharges these are
historically what victorians used in
fact to protect
sewage backing up into people's homes
which is obviously not something we want
or indeed into people's streets which is
not something we want either but the
problem is that the water companies are
now over using them and using them in
times when they don't really need to
they're for emergencies they're to stop
um an even worse sewage situation in
people's homes so
we have got a really comprehensive plan
being published at the moment
to make sure that water companies reduce
their reliance on these these outflows
really as soon as is possible and the
other thing that we're doing is making
sure that the way that sewage when it is
sadly occasionally having to be got rid
of in that way that the water companies
are very transparent about that so that
people know exactly what is happening
we've brought through the new
environment act last year which gives um
much greater regulatory control over
water companies we've got record
prosecutions of
water companies at the moment which is
definitely the way to go this is this is
a totally unacceptable situation and we
need to do everything we can to make
sure that the water companies put in the
investment tell people what's going on
and stop relying on these outflows
okay and just finally then you would
have seen the front page of the times
newspaper this morning i'm sure that has
uh um a poll that says that conservative
voters
overwhelmingly back nationalization of
energy companies i mean are they wrong
to think that that might be a way of
alleviating this crisis
i think they probably are it's obviously
a difficult time for everybody looking
at rises in
energy bills
and thinking how could we as a country
and a government react to those
increases
we have seen over the years that
competition in the market has kept
energy prices low the difficulty is that
of course what what a cap and what
nationalization can't do is mean that
people's bills are cheaper than the
wholesale price of gas
so
i don't feel that there is more in the
way that we structure our system that
would really help what we have to do now
as government is make sure that we step
up and support people particularly the
most vulnerable households through this
difficulty with energy bills this winter
but the blame should be put fair fairly
and squarely on vladimir putin i'm
afraid these bills are rising because of
the war
okay victoria apprentice mp supporter
richie soon i do appreciate your time
this morning thank you have a good day
thank you
now police in merseyside say that they
have made 170 rests and seized a
significant number of vehicles a large
amount of drugs and firearms in just the
past week now the operation targeting
serious and organized crime has been
held all across the region and comes
just a week after nine-year-old olivia
corbell was shot dead inside her home in
the city of liverpool shingi marike
reports
[Music]
streets away from the scene of her death
a service dedicated to the memory of
olivia pratt corbell
for a vicar who spent the week trying to
soothe a community in shock reflecting
on the pain olivia's family must be
feeling was almost too much
what do we say or do when something so
unspeakably horrific as may there
happens in our own community even worse
than method of a child who was in what
should have been the safest place in the
world in their own home with her
with her mum
here they've spent the week saying
prayers lighting candles and sending
their condolences
i think it's disbelief and shock and
fear but there's hope you know people
will come together and i really hope
that the people that have done this get
brought to justice
words fail you just don't can't
comprehend it to be honest it's just
why are people doing this why are they
carrying these knives guns and
destroying lives and we just asked them
to draw what they the message from their
sunday school
a simple one and i can see that one of
them
the area outside her home is still taped
off with officers doing everything they
can to move this investigation forward
continue to gather evidence at the scene
the two men have arrested have been
released on bail police have taken the
unusual step of releasing a video asking
for more information
we've got a nine-year-old girl who won't
celebrate their 18th birthday the city's
mayor says liverpool can move past this
violence across the whole of the region
actually and much further beyond that
our messages of support
you know
liverpool is not like this this is not a
typical of what happens here um the
community support here is enormous
you'll you'll see
solidarity like nowhere else one of
those messages from a man who drove more
than 200 miles to pay his respects it
just shouldn't be happening
it shouldn't be happening at all
knife climb gun climb everything so it's
all got to stop
it's all got to stop olivia's life cut
short has shocked her community
but still the police are calling for
help with their investigation to find
her killer shingi maraike sky news
liverpool
okay some of this morning's other news
now and a 16 year old boy has died at
the music festival in leeds
police believe he may have taken an
ecstasy tablet before falling ill on
saturday night west yorkshire police
have launched an investigation into what
they say was an isolated incident
a team from the international atomic
energy agency will visit the zaparizia
nuclear power plant in ukraine this week
the head of the agency rafael grossi is
going to lead the mission saying he
wants to protect the safety and security
of ukraine and europe's biggest nuclear
facility
the royal navy's largest aircraft
carrier which sell from portsmouth
yesterday following delays due to
technical problems has now broken down
off the coast of the isle of wight
divers are said to be inspecting hms
prince of wales with reports suggesting
there is damage to the vessel's
propeller shaft the ship cost three
billion pounds
well the rocket is on the launch pad
ahead of nasa's first test mission
before sending humans back to the moon
the agency plans to make history when it
goes back to the lunar service in 2025
by sending the first female the first
non-white person to step on that surface
but today they'll be making sure that
the rocket system just works as it
should david blevins reports
it stands taller than the statue of
liberty signaling the dawn of a new era
in space exploration the aim of nasa's
artemis program to return humans to the
moon
it's one small step for man
one
diabetes
with the orion command capsule at the
center this is the most powerful rocket
ever built
its maiden voyage an unmanned test
mission overseen by a new generation of
engineers they're very wide-eyed and and
doing again a fantastic job we have some
extremely smart people that have come up
very quickly through the ranks to to get
the positions that they now hold in the
firing room and we have trained and
trained to get them to the level at so
that they would be ready to support this
launch countdown and everybody has to
have a first one right and this is going
to be the first for for a great number
of people in that room we're going to
the moon
if all goes to plan they hope to land
the first woman and first person of
color on the moon by 2025
keeping america ahead of china
we're in a space race
and
we want to get to the south pole of the
moon where the resources are where we
think water is if there's water there's
rocket fuel
and we don't want china suddenly getting
there and saying ah this is our
exclusive territory it's a quarter of a
million miles to the moon and artemis
one will go 40 000 miles beyond that
further than any spacecraft equipped to
carry humans has gone before
but even that is just the start of this
journey nasa hopes to establish a
permanent moon base the first step to
putting humans on mars
nasa has registered thousands of watch
parties here in america and around the
world it'll be the most consequential
liftoff in a generation and artemis one
is go for launch
david blevins sky news cape canaveral
florida
and this is the latest live picture from
cape canaveral in florida is uh
0 2 24 in the morning there as you can
see in the left hand of your screen that
is the countdown before the space launch
system
there on the launch pad blasts off into
orbits it's just a test mission as david
was saying uh before
planned um
mission to the moon in around
2025. nasa planning to send people back
to the lunar surface for the first time
in 50 years but in five and a half hours
time this test flight of the nasa's new
space launch system as part of the
artemis program is going to blast off
from that launch pad in cape canaveral
and when that happens you'll see it here
on sky news
all right let's take a look at what the
weather has in store for us here i think
it's fine in florida
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now it's going to be mostly fine and dry
today but there will be a few showers
around
northern scotland northern england
ireland and northern ireland they're
going to see a little patchy rain while
a few showers are likely near south
eastern coasts the morning is going to
be fine for most although it will feel
quite cloudy overall with western parts
seeing the best of the sunshine there'll
be just
a few showers about mainly over northern
and eastern parts of both britain and
ireland
all right let's go back to the cost of
living crisis now we're never not there
really and warnings that people are
already scrambling to pay their rising
energy bills researchers found that more
than two in five people aged 55 to 64
say they are struggling financially or
the report says they're up to their neck
in debt well let's bring in the charity
director at age uk caroline abrams uh
good morning to you karen abrams and
thank you very much for being with us
just talk us through some of the ways
that older people are being affected
particularly by the energy crisis we're
seeing yeah well the group that you've
just been mentioning they're people who
haven't yet reached their state
retirement age so they might be working
but a lot of people by that stage in
life have been knocked out of the labour
market for one reason or other they
might be caring they might be unwell
they might be disabled and so their
reliance on universal credit like
younger people are which is not very
generous as we all know
and your costs tend to go up as you get
older as well so for people in that
position
life is really tough it's it's also
pretty tough once you do get to state
pension age because the state pension
isn't very generous either it's less
certainly well less than 10 000 pounds a
year for people and it's very hard to
live on that and people are often very
good at budgeting you know they had a
lifetime of knowing how to manage their
money uh but however hard you budget you
can't cope with these kinds of price
rises that are coming down the track
which is why the government is going to
have to intervene and give quite a big
package of support yeah well just give
us an idea of what you're expecting to
see from government to try and help this
particular group in society yeah well
several things i mean firstly firstly
not everybody has benefited from the
money that's come through already though
there are some groups that are missing
out unfortunately niche groups but
important groups people on pre-payment
meters aren't always getting the money
they're due
people living in park homes in those
static caravans which is quite common as
people get older
they're missing out and people in
northern ireland need more support as
well their government's arrangements are
a sort of meaning that they're not
getting all their due
but the government is going to have to
come through particularly to target
money to people on the lowest incomes
whether they're below or above the state
pension age and i think a bit to help
everybody because these price rises are
so huge that we don't want to see a huge
cliff edge so that if you're just below
the uh the poverty line then you get
some money but if you're just above a
few pence a week even then you get
nothing and longer term i mean but
actually coming down the track really
quickly these caps aren't working very
well are they these price caps i think
we we think that a social tariff would
be much better it's what we see in some
other utilities and we used to have one
in energy as well time to bring those
back and let's start insulating people's
homes particularly people on very low
incomes it would make a huge difference
to their bills yeah it's really
interesting i mean we've heard a lot
about social terrorists the past few
weeks and you'll see there's a line this
morning about the lack of insulation
about a number for a number of people's
homes the labour party is saying now i
mean while this conservative leadership
race has been going on for the past
couple of months do you think there's
been enough discussion about this
particular age group not just people who
are at the retirement age but the people
in this age group that we're talking
about here from age 55 to 64. there's
been enough focus on them yeah i think
that has to be honest i think obviously
not everybody who's in that age group is
is in dire straits there are lots of
people in that in those groups who are
doing okay and although the bills will
be worrying they won't be terrifying um
it's people across the board in our
society who haven't got much money who
we need to worry about the most whether
they're 20 or 40 or 85 i mean they all
need extra help and that's where it
should come from i think what's been
difficult for people is that during the
leadership race uh obviously politicians
have had other things to think about and
they haven't been able to give the
concrete reassurance that people are
looking for that they're going to be
okay this winter and that's what i think
a lot of people are worried about you
know it's a nice day today it's a bank
holiday in england wales and northern
ireland uh you know we're enjoying the
last of the summer but before we know it
the weather will be getting worse it'll
be much colder you know we don't have
our heating in our in our homes for
nothing it's there to do a job and if
people can't afford to run it
that's going to be very worrying and of
course particularly for older people who
do need to stay warm in order to stay
fit and well
yeah absolutely right okay uh caroline
abrams from um ajk do you appreciate
your time this morning thank you
now trades unions are threatening months
of coordinated disruption as they ask
for better pay and working conditions
well the trades union congress is also
calling on the governments to introduce
four more bank holidays between summer
and christmas to bring workers in
england and wales in line with the eu
average let's bring in kate bell head of
economics at the trades union conquest
who's joining us now live kate bell good
morning to you and thank you for being
with us so look the uk's got record low
productivity it's only behind russia as
being worse in terms of productivity so
explain how having more bank holidays is
going to help the economy
well i don't think workers taking time
off is behind our productivity problems
many countries such as germany denmark
france who have much higher productivity
than us also have higher
higher numbers of bank holidays and we
think workers in the uk who work some of
the longest hours in europe to 37
billion pounds worth a year of unpaid
overtime do deserve that time off like
their colleagues in european countries
now of course we saw yesterday that
there is um
discussion uh which will be at the tuc
congress next week of a coordinated
action for workers are we just getting
close to having a general strike here
well look every strike has taken place
because of the democratic decision in a
workplace and the tuc is a democratic
organization so we'll listen to what
workers in those workplaces want to see
and we'll listen to what our unions tell
us at our congress but what i think most
people understand is that people have
been really pushed to the brink by the
terrible cost of living crisis we're
experiencing which is coming on top of
the longest wage squeeze we've seen for
200 years and real attacks on people's
pay and conditions you know what workers
want is decent pay rise they want their
jobs protected and when they're taking
strike action that's really kind of the
last resort
yeah but the sort of the threat of
coordinated strike action um with the uh
most likely next prime minister to be
liz trust who's already said that she's
gonna try and legislate for minimum
service levels are we setting up a
potential clash with the next person in
number 10 between the unions and the
government
well look we've always been willing to
talk to governments and what we'd like
to hear from this trust is a plan for
how she's going to address the cost of
living crisis
not kind of distractions through attacks
on working people who just want a decent
pay rise of course we're ready to talk
to liz trust about the support that
people need we've been calling for an
emergency
price
freeze to the energy price cap and we've
been launching our fight for a 15-pound
minimum wage we'd love to be talking to
liz trust about those issues we don't
want to be distracted by pointless
attacks on working people
i mean how strong do you think the union
movement is right now i mean people will
be seeing you know
trains not running buses not running in
scotland rubbish not being collected um
i mean do you understand how some people
in the general public might be really
upset by that and that might actually
put them off the idea of unionising and
organized labour
well i think what people understand
right now is you know strikes always a
lot of their jobs but they've been
pushed to the brink by this kind of 200
year 200 year record long high squeeze
and i think people do understand that
you know people need to stand up for
their paying conditions our message to
everybody looking at these strikes and
thinking all right they're fighting for
better pay rises to join the union and
of course we'll fight for a better pay
rise for you too
and okay um you will have seen that the
uh header unite yesterday uh called for
the labour party to be a more fulfilled
more um
forceful in their support from unions is
that something the tuc would would back
to see the labour party being more
behind um unions and their members well
look the tuc wants to talk to all
political parties and of course we want
people to be supporting workers and
recognizing
their you know
their struggle for better paying
conditions that's what we're about we'll
talk to anybody who wants to talk about
that now and you know what we want is
employers to come forward with decent
pay rises to help people through the
really difficult winter that we're all
facing
okay uh kate bell from the tc appreciate
your time and thank you
thank you
let's take a look at the morning's
papers now and to do that again is the
uk editor of the big issue paul mcnamee
and the author and broadcaster emma wolf
paul emma good to have you back with us
thanks for sticking around i know you've
got much better things to be doing all
right let's uh go to the front page of
the guardian we'll start off with uh um
sorry not the front page page seven of
the guidelines the story that we are
covering at the top of our bulletins
this is about one in four people in the
country saying that they're not going to
turn their heating on
this winter
yeah so this is a another well yet more
worrying data more worrying analysis um
about the about the cost of living
crisis around one in four adults saying
that they will not be able to turn the
heating on at all this winter um this is
a poll from cervantes study
showing that the numbers actually could
be even higher um for those with
children under 18 and that's really
worrying obviously because people with
children under 18 are the ones with
young children who need to actually
keep the home warm even more so than
normal people it was actually a study
commissioned by the lib dems and they've
called the results heartbreaking um
seven in ten also have said that they'll
put the heating on much less and we've
got a dire winter coming you know
everybody is saying there's a dire
winter ahead the energy price cap as we
know
rising to 80 rising about 80 percent um
in october with the average price
of energy around three and a half
thousand but that could be as high as
seven
thousand next april
um and there's a real sense obviously
from the lib dems but in general um and
paul referenced this earlier a real
sense that the government and that our
our leaders our politicians are sort of
you know current and future prime
minister have have been missing in
action on this one that they should have
come up with something a little bit more
workable than
nibbling around the edges talking about
possible tax cuts
sending out 400 pounds to you know
certain sectors that there really needs
we really need to hear some concerted
action on this yeah thank you for that
uh paul if you don't mind i'll just keep
us moving on uh because you haven't got
loads of time i won't go to the front
page of the daily mail this is a story
that you picked out here this is um
let's bring up the headline if we can
hospitals hit by 5.5 million pound a day
bed blocking crisis the mail say that
not a bed blocker on the front page
that's lewis hamilton apparently but
paul tell us about the story on the
front page there
yes just as you um outlined the the male
have found that one in seven patients
who are fit for discharge
hospitals
are not being discharged um and this
on top of the cost of living crisis and
the energy crisis
what's happening in the nhs is going to
be
a
major
problem that will have to be dealt with
by the incoming um prime minister
the the meals has found it costs about
5.5 million a day to keep people who
should be discharged from hospital in
hospital um i should say this looking
like it's hospitals in england and wales
rather than in scotland as well because
that's separate and it's devolved but
they they think that there's 13 000 beds
13 000 pets filled with patients who are
ready to leave but they just can't
either because
staff of staffing issues or their um
their own social care beds for them to
go to and of course this then compounds
problems with that we've seen all
through the summer and then dig through
from springtime with ambulances queuing
up at a e they can't um have people go
into a e because people can't be
discharged from any into hospital and so
on and so forth so this is not something
that is easily fixed but it's something
that needs to be
got into not just because of the cost
which is spiraling but because of what
it means for people for their well-being
for their families if you're ready to go
home from hospital how disparate and how
terrible it is that you're maintained in
hospital and and
as with a number of these things there
doesn't seem to be
a clear and coherent plan to deal with
this no there's not
i mean the 40 new hospitals as we've
i've seen was perhaps not the solution
to deal with it was it emma there seems
to be a real concern here that um
there's just not enough space and
there's not enough money to go around to
make sure that the social care and the
healthcare system are funded properly
exactly i think paul's absolutely right
this points to the broken healthcare
system all the health and social care
system that we have obviously the
national insurance price-wise which is
set to be reversed who's supposed to be
going to deal with this and really try
and start funding social care properly
but no we have a system that's
completely broken that you know older
people more vulnerable people are simply
being
as you say left in hospitals kept in
hospitals unnecessarily at huge expense
and a huge
you know discomfort to themselves they
don't want to be there if they're not if
they're not medically unwell um and yet
they can't be sent home so yeah this is
just bed blocking uh it's a horrible
term but it's yeah it's a well-broken
system at the moment yeah it is a
horrible term but i guess it's a real
situation that people are facing in in
hospitals all right let's uh move on to
um
a story inside the telegraph family that
you've picked out this is about carnival
now i was there yesterday i had a great
time with my wife and my boy but there
weren't as many floats as we were
expecting and uh this story i think
tells us a little bit why doesn't it
yeah it does so this is the um the mayor
of london was saying you know if we
thought we could escape the cost of
living in crisis kamali by going to the
carnival um sadly not the mayor of
london sadiq khan has one has been
saying that the carnival's return to the
capital has actually been quite
negatively affected by these spiraling
costs of bills
many of those people who wanted to take
part who wanted to have floats and sound
systems and all of that have not been
able to attend um
although he did say that he did say that
they said on social media the vibes are
immaculate i think that's his way of
being cool is that his is that like i
mean vibes
it was a lovely vibe day yesterday we
had we had a great time
all that were there but the vibes are
immaculate it just doesn't seem like
something that sadiq khan will come out
with but it is lovely that the west
london street party is back after three
years
no it really wasn't it was good to go
there paul i won't ask you if you're a
carnival there with the felonious monk
behind your shoulder i'm sure you do
love your music but this is a story
about musical instruments that you've
picked out for inside the times and i
really should have picked up that guitar
again when i put it down as a teenager
well this this is actually a good story
amongst unremittingly miserable and dark
stories there have been pieces of
research through the years that suggest
that if you play a musical instrument um
earlier in life it will have a positive
uh impact later in life and this is
further research that seems to um
to say that that is that is a truth it
comes from university of edinburgh study
um
it's on octogenarians in scotland who
played instruments early in life and has
found that their cognitive
ability is sharper had they played those
instruments
it comes with a slight caveat in that
two of those instruments are accordions
and bagpipes which
just
like but not perhaps for people who are
listening to people learning
accordions
it is from the lothian birth
cohort from 1936 i just wanted to
mention one thing the the person quoted
in this has got one of the best titles i
have heard i have read in a story
it's a guy called ian deary he's my
amateurs
professor but for
he was director of university for the uh
of edinburgh centre for cognac
we'll get the title next time
all right more to come from sky news
breakfast next time we'll get that title
as well from paul